hi my name is Lorna growler Dell and I
was wondering what advice would you give
young scientists and students that are
thinking about research how to figure
out what areas to do research in or what
if I just yeah you our heart is very shy
so the subject of research is very
important you have is important to go in
a direction well armed anything to do
and I think you ought to hit articles to
read books and also a direct contact
with the research is also important so
what is very important for young
students is internships in laboratory
with many discussion with researchers
and what we are to avoid is the
direction in which most of the results
have been already obtained you have to
to find direction where there is many
thing to explore